[Music]
okay
15 plus 10 ladies and gentlemen let's go
like i said guys
i would like to vary our opening choices
a little bit as we hit 1600 i played the
queen's gamut declined exclusively
throughout the speedrun so far but i
want to introduce you to a couple of
interesting sidelines that i recommend
to players and one of them is the baltic
which i played in my five minute speed
run the original speeder and i want to
play it again here and let's see how it
fares in a 15 minute game
the baltic is this move bishop f5 those
of you new to my stream
uh you're probably not familiar with
this move but i've had previous streams
where i
you know explained this in depth i
taught half of this move
and uh all talk about all things opening
after the game
queen b3 is not one of the most common
moves but it is one of the most
challenging okay now queen b3 exploits
the drawback of bishop f5 it gets the
queen out it attacks b7 and you
basically need to know what to do here
right it's very very hard for black to
come up with a move
if if you are seeing this position for
the first time because
you know pawn on b7 hangs pawn on d5 is
hanging
what we basically need to do here is
just keep developing our pieces we need
to close our eyes pretend that nothing
is being attacked and just develop our
pieces
now which piece should we develop you
know knight c6 he plays c takes you know
what the problem is with knight c6 he
plays c takes d5 and if we take on d4
there's a check on a4 which wins the
knight
well it's not b6 because then c takes d5
hm
is it e6 takes an 87 no
it might be d take c4 queen takes b7
knight t7
no it's definitely not 97 here i think
it's either d take c4
or i mean one way or another we
sacrifice the pawn on b7 this is the
pawn we want to sacrifice
uh so that so that we get at least
uh initiative against white's queen i
think it's d take c4
by the way queen b5 check does not win
the bishop because we can drop it back
or we can cover with the queen
i thought it was knight c6 but it's not
okay queen b7
obviously our rook is attacked so we
have to go knight d7
essentially in the baltic in many of
these variations you bank on rapid
development literally you throw
everything
you throw caution to the wind you throw
caution to the wind and the only thing
that you care about is
quick development
and opening up the center early
um so in the name of developing rapidly
what should we do should we try to cling
to this pawn with bishop e6 uh
that looks ugly
no we shouldn't go e5 yet because after
d d takes c5 we cannot recapture and we
just go knight gf6 only after queen
takes c4
can we consider opening up the center
with e5 in fact i think it's time for us
to open up the center
why how do i know that well because
we've got three pieces developed and
white has zero
right so if we are to exploit our
leading development
i propose that we try to do that now
right rather than procrastinating and
letting white consolidate
should be logical to everybody we play
e5
now the baltic is a dubious opening
objectively but from a practical
perspective it's a very interesting
opening at this at this approximate
level 1600.
okay d e
well obviously i take
and uh one very important detail queen
b5 check yes
it looks like it wins a piece but it
doesn't
and yet black needs to be very precise
very precise
what is black's move trick question
not pawn c6 because you lose the the e5
knight you have to cover with the knight
but which one well if you cover with the
e knight you lose the bishop that's very
important thing to notice
knight fd7 that's san pellegrino this is
a little bit awkward but so is white's
queen white's queen can now be targeted
by the rook the bishop can come out to
b4
this could get very dangerous for white
very dangerous and i'm sure that white
is better objectively speaking but
practically
you know this is this is a lot of fun
let's put it that way
yeah white's queen is just sort of
stumbling around it's hungover bishop f4
okay so our opponent develops a piece
now the by the way the way my brain
works like the moment bishop f4 is
played
the first thing that i i kind of
noticed or paid attention to was the
pawn on b2
now uh no longer being defended by the
bishop
all right that's the first thing i kind
of saw in in a moment
now we have to figure out whether that
can be exploited and it obviously it can
be rugby 8 comes to mind bishop d6 also
comes to mind good move bishop d6 is a
great move developing another piece
but if we are to play more ambitiously
this seems like a great opportunity to
play rook beat
but i don't see why bishop d6 first is
necessary guys because rook b8 attacks
the queen
it's not like white can capture the
knight right so
i don't see the downside to deploying
our rook first
and then we can decide based on where
the queen goes whether we need to play
bishop d6
does that make sense
just logical
a white is already in trouble i think
because abandoning this this pawn was
not a good idea does the move voter
matter here well yes it does i think i
think bishop d6 is decent but it gives
white
an opportunity thank you for the
opportunity it gives white an
opportunity to
uh to move the queen away
preemptively
and now we're winning
and now we're winning
how do we win
very good anita
bishop on f4 is an undefended piece
well egolian not really
a lot of you i'm sure are thinking about
this check
and that's definitely tempting and it's
not bad but there is a better move we
can go rook b4
goodbye bishop
and it only took us 10 minutes 10 moves
boom boom knight c5 is illegal the
knight is pinned
and once we take the bishop we still
have our initiative but now we have an
extra piece
okay queen takes a7
all right
now a great lesson in not uh making any
automatic moves
a lot of people would take the bishop
here but if you want to be accurate
what do you start with
what do you start with absolutely bishop
c5 you get the bishop out first and then
you take on f4 and this is getting more
and more devastating by the move
and obviously when i tell you that there
is a different move you find it
instantly the challenge is
that during a game there's nobody to tap
you on the shoulder
and and say that you know there's a move
like this but it's all it's a mentality
thing right it's just it's all about
uh setting yourself up with a mentality
that
you don't play automatically on any move
you always look for the best that you
can do yeah just look at the development
i mean it's crazy after we take the
bishop why we'll have zero pieces
developed i mean this might be resigns
queen a6 or four now we take
obviously
although maybe even there we had a
better move
there was there was stuff we could have
done there e3
okay
the hilarious thing is we could probably
castle and we'd still be winning
yeah the lead in development i i don't
think i've ever seen a legion
development like this now if i was
playing a classical game i would spend
some time calculating rook takes f2
sacking the rokin
hunting the king once it lands on f2 but
for the sake of the speed run i don't
want to bog ourselves down with this
kind of speculative play thank you
righteous judas so instead i propose
that we make a very simple move and we
move the rook away to b4 okay bishop
before check i don't like because knight
c3
oh wait a minute maybe there's a follow
up there let me think but should before
check knight c3
aha
there is a follow-up there what is it
bishop b4 check knight c3 looks like
we're helping white develop
but in reality we have a crushing move
there
now think about which squares are now
accessible to your pieces after bishop
before check
the bishop has moved itself from c5
that's a hint
we can go knight c5
okay so bishop before check knight c3
knight c5 what does that accomplish
well it attacks the queen
what happens if the queen moves there
well the queen doesn't even have
anywhere to move
but where are these knights going
what is the purpose of bringing your
other knight to c5
d3 and once the knight gets to d3 the
game is over
check
knight c3 knight c5 and probably we're
going to end up winning a queen for for
something
and now knight c5
get in there knight is coming to d3 well
then play the ball play the baltic if
you want to have positions like these
yeah he played queen b3 very confidently
but things went downhill from there okay
it's over
okay queen b5 check one final accurate
move is required what is the best way to
cover the check
ideally we want to do it with tempo
obviously
c6
c6 and everything is protecting each
other that's it and my recommendation
it's good to have one main opening and
then sort of one
gambity sort of baltic-y kind of line
which you don't play quite as frequently
but exists just so you can practice your
tactics and you know so you can pull it
out at certain moments just to mix it up
baltic i've already played the chigorin
albin is another one such opening
okay e takes f4
now
even here we can play a little bit more
accurately than c takes b5
well actually no we can't let's just
take the queen
i thought for a moment then white could
take with the bishop but then we can
block with our knight the very same
knight that's being attacked can block
that check and we keep that knight
on top of everything else now let's
finish the game off let's not let's not
let white back in the game
and when i say that i think a lot of you
right now are probably thinking let's go
knight d3 check you know let's go bishop
d let's go queen d4
uh but but i'm going to make a move
which looks like it probably lets white
off the hook i propose that we simply
castle right because after we castle and
i love to see that a lot of you are
saying this
it just removes a headache right bishop
takes b5 check
by castling you're completely freeing
yourself for the decisive attack
okay now where should the queen go
where should the queen
go
think about putting pressure on this
knight
yeah queen a5 this is all very easy
no need to spend long on these moves
okay what now
we have a a totally devastating move
right now
like at this very moment there is a
crushing move
not knight d3 check
not bishop d3
nobody has said it so far you guys are
fixating too much on the center and not
enough on all sides of the board
very good queen takes a2
queen takes a2 and then queen takes b2
it's because of this pin the moment the
queen went to a5
and i've said this before it's important
to to understand everything that a piece
is doing not just
pay attention to one main thread and
then forget about it right so as soon as
you played queen a5 you could have said
okay well i'm threatening to take on c3
but if you look more carefully you're
also threatening to take on a2
and then take on b2
and the rest is
okay 92 maybe white is actually going to
be able to castle which is kind of funny
okay we have a gazillion ways to win
here
essentially the easiest approach is is
to win another minor piece
the easiest approach is to is to capture
another minor piece
and the most clinical way of doing that
something which perhaps you guys aren't
noticing the queen is x-raying the
bishop
so the simplest move is bishop takes
knight check
either we win the rook or we we take the
bishop there is a again don't buggers
yeah finally resigns
and uh the game was ended up pretty
one-sided
all right so now we can use opening
explorer
oh the move here is actually e5 this is
the move i had forgotten
it's like an album on steroids
yeah this is the move now i remember
queen b7 97 and this leads to a very
chaotic position
where
white pays the price for not developing
anything but the queen i i remember
analyzing this and thinking that in this
line black is fine even objectively
so the move here is e5 not dc4
dc4 is wrong
but
the the rationale behind playing the
baltic
is pretty straightforward it's like you
want to play a queen's gamut decline but
you don't want to keep the bishop behind
the pawn chain
so from a positional perspective it's a
very sound opening
but there are concrete issues with the
baltic primarily the fact that white can
play c takes d5
and the point here is not to recapture
with the queen this just looks like a
terrible scandy
but the point is to take white's knight
before it gets a chance to develop
and then take on d5 with the queen and
then quickly get your queen side out
knight c6 castle's queen side and then
e5
so i'm not going to talk about it
here in this video because i've had
other videos where i talk about it
and uh you know i might make a separate
dedicated opening video on the baltic so
i don't want to
bore people to death here
but
all i want to say is that it's something
you can consider as an alternative to
chigorin or queen's gambit
okay so queen b3 dc queen b7 knight d7
and my guess i think queen c6 is already
a mistake i think
white starts going wrong here
i think the crucial
uh move for white is just to go knight
c3 and white is much better because e4
is coming with tempo and then bishop
takes c4 white tried to do everything
with his queen
and that's just not a good strategy when
you have nothing developed
um
maybe e4 is is okay here but i think we
have rook bait in this position and the
queen is unable to keep the pawn on e4
protected it loses contact
so
the best move here is
i'm 99 sure knight c3
yeah the slav sometimes it does
okay
so queen b797 queen c6
we get our night out once again knight
c3
it's not too late
for white to revert to
the correct strategy
queen 64 is i think a serious mistake at
least from a practical perspective after
e5 and at every move white
more and more urgently had to develop a
piece so here for example white had to
go knight f3 but our opponent just like
kept moving his queen
and when he decided to develop a piece
it was the wrong piece that left the b2
pawn undefended
what should white have done here which
piece should he have developed
well if f4 we have rook b8 anyway
although already it's getting quite iffy
yeah probably knight c3 or knight f3
knight c3
and if we go rook b8 perhaps the queen
can
park itself back on its initial square
although this is looking very shady
after bishop before
this is looking mighty mighty sketchy
for white
so already it's very very iffy
but after bishop f4 rook b8 i think
black is simply winning
because white is so overwhelmed here
and this just shows you how important
development is it's just impossible to
play a game of chess without developing
your pieces
okay maybe queen a6 was more marginally
more resilient but this is game over i
mean bishop is coming to before with
totally devastating effect
so a good lesson in the fact that nobody
is immune from this right you can be 2
800 and if you don't have anything
developed you're going to lose in five
moves
does that make sense any questions we
don't have to we don't have to analyze
the rest of the game after queen a
forward before i think everything else
was very straightforward
uh once we win the bishop and get the
rest of our pieces out
when he went e3 could you have taken on
b1 when did he go e3 oh here
could i have taken here oh so you want
to give a bishop before check so the
knight can't block
i'm sure the answer is yes yeah this
looks great as well
maybe rook takes b1 but then maybe maybe
y can go like this and the king is still
okay here
yeah maybe maybe white should go like
this and of course black is winning but
white is still kicking
so
i think i like the way that we played we
i think we found the best
uh the most accurate continuation
because the knight is getting into d3
which is totally crushing um
and that's that
to what level with the baltic walk no
the baltic is has been played at the gm
level there's a book actually by a
russian grandmaster on the ball tickets
it's not bad it white is better in
several different ways but that doesn't
mean an opening is is discredited
right i mean white is not
winning at
in the baltic and even some gm's have
struggled against me to to find the best
lines people just don't tend to
study it i think it's my best get off
you can you can look up this guy's last
name on google
and then
find his book i'm pretty sure it's my
best got off
which means without years in russian
no it is the liberated bishop defense
the liberated bishop defense that's what
he calls it
it's a pretty old book there's a lot of
holes in it but i mean if you're an
opening book collector you can get it
[Music]